oh hey I didn't see you there check out
this shirt it's my limited edition one
you're watching this on upload day you
got five days until this is never
available ever ever ever again
so if you want it go check out the
corridor - digital comm store it's the
first link in the description go buy
your shirt you got five days till the
morning of the fifth and then it's never
available ever again like this what are
we doing today all right excuse nouns
Carmichael now is going to learn how to
fly a DJI phantom for another noun with
Sam also a noun and we are going to do
that on the roof of the Hunter Street
building also noun the context yeah I
don't believe it is more of a
superstitious thing but I like to get
everything all connected up and ready on
the controller side first before even
getting the drone on because of the
slight minimal possibility that the
drone goes rogue how did you drive
connected to the phone I'm going to open
up the eji Go app and just put it in
there like so just like that I press too
hard
anyways I'll do it a little more gently
this time can't connect to the ghost the
drones none on so now let's turn the
drone on full blue aircraft connected so
this thing's super easy to use you want
to go through camera stuff where you
want to go through flight stuff let's
start with flight lights easy all right
both sticks into the corner Hey exactly
the same let's say you're flying and you
want to do all your stuff you have a
fancy little record button right there -
okay this one right here is your camera
tilt so you can look up and down so I
can only tilt the camera I can't pan it
nope that's all the drone body that's
that's actual piloting at that point
you've got you you always want to cut
your video clip before you turn off the
drone someone walks up catches the drone
and turns it off you'll most likely lose
your video clip really just just a heads
up okay I think you have everything you
need to know to film the full shot I
think it's your time to shine
[Music]
that's a pretty low exposure value yeah
so up is darker down is brighter yes
hey guys have you ever wondered how to
actually throw a Nerf dart middle finger
thumb hold it here
use the back to stabilizing I'll see if
I can do this you ready what happens if
you don't do it right I'll just kind of
like wiggle and flop the trick is to not
try to throw it with this finger you got
to throw it with these two you have to
use the back on a stabilize if you do
this half the time I'll just be able to
blue start at the back see if I can hit
Jake
I have a sink web there yeah did you see
it
okay this one I'll have to throw a
little bit lighter so I don't throw it
too far make it not amused at all those
whom sorry
that was a poor time to mess with Jake
business mode right now tell me okay so
this is the battery right here 66% right
yeah at what percent should I be like I
need to lay them now they'll usually say
you're is you what you do when you come
back plan the only give you a bunch of
warnings that's about 33 33 yeah 30% is
gives the F back here right now
otherwise it's going to follow this guy
there's a little mini map that will show
you the orientation of the drone which
weights facing and also show you its
position in space relative to where you
took it off when you lose sight of it or
forget orientation let's say even in the
screen too long it's always nice to take
a look at that and it'll help reorient
you really quickly in case you've lost
sight of it about this I'm gonna teach
you how to use the little map I'm going
to disorient you and disorient the drone
so you don't know where it is maybe you
might be able to hear it don't don't
look at it right now for a minute not
looking so I'm not I'm not gonna tell
you where I'm flying it but I'm gonna
fly it somewhere ideally you'll be just
far enough away so you can't hear it for
see you alright then I can't see the
drone okay
the left find it red arrow is the drone
and you're the line with dot red arrow
is the drill yeah
there it is there you go cool you been
hey Karma
do you want me to look at that or you
what do you wanna look at what does
everyone else looking at I wanna be the
only guy not looking in the right place
he lived up to the roof hey Carmichael
what are you even doing here though
currently I'm editing Aki junkyard
escape junkie the normally you're not
here yeah I am now working with corridor
to help in any capacity that night need
I worked at Hunter starting in April of
2011 so I have been associated with this
building for five years and five months
you were one of the first people I met
when I visited here yeah when I started
doing henna scenes for like this channel
you gave me a tip I'll never forget you
like just punch in like 20% on some
shots so just like you get a little bit
of variety even though it's the same
shot it's stuck with me I was like
you're so right it's the same shot I
just scale up so as it kind of goes on
it feels slightly defective smells like
a lot and I completely ignore that flow
even if you're doing the jump cuts like
right now like I'm saying this one thing
but then I make a different point and
now I'm back to my original point if you
scale on my different point it's gonna
look like it was a completely different
part of the interview so landing is very
critical if you're ever going to screw
up your drone it's most likely when you
land it as you get closer to the ground
there's a lot of turbulence because the
air of the propellers is hitting the
ground and making it shaky also there's
generally a lot of wind nice and low
that's like might bump you
move it quickly in my closet to tip so
when you land it land with confidence
basically once you're level with the
ground and you're like getting close
just keep lowering don't don't be afraid
of the wobbles the board confidence
now nice my place
confidence you're good no-win confidence
down down down down down down down go
hold it hold it hold it there you go
done that's very confident landing you
do not imagine a 29% - well it's all the
first flight I bet you roll all right
just a little bit next lesson show me
how to use the automatic pilot yeah
autopilot